AMIT FULAY: Good afternoon, and
welcome to the session.
My name is Amit Fulay.
I'm the product manager
for Google+ Hangouts.
And I'm going to be joined
here today by
Pamela Fox from Coursera.
We have a great session for you
today, because I'm really
excited to talk about two
areas that have seen an
amazing amount of innovation
happen in the last few years,
online education and social,
specifically Google+.
This is what you can expect
in the next 30 minutes.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about the profound change that
we're witnessing.
Then, I'll jump into some of the
Google+ features that can
help, and we'll look at a couple
of case studies of
actual implementation of
some of these ideas.
So let me start by reflecting
a little bit on the change
that we've all seen.
We've gone from an era of
traditional classrooms to
connected classrooms, from a
time when all of us carried
huge amounts of textbooks in our
backpacks to a time when
we carry a small number of
devices in our pockets.
We can now learn at our own pace
and only advance once we
are sure of having mastered a
concept, and we can pretty
much do that from anywhere.
This change has been
revolutionary.
It has brought the costs
of education down.
And not just for a lucky and
privileged few, but for
everyone, without ever
compromising on
the quality of content.
But the change has not
all been easy.
There are challenges with
online education.
And if you were to talk to some
of the students who've
taken these courses, who tried
to study these concepts, these
are the common refrains you're
going to hear from them.
They will say, this is hard.
A lot of times, this is a
very lonely experience.
And honestly.
it's incredibly boring
at times.
Now, if you were to look at the
data, that's the picture
you would see.
This is a typical dropout funnel
for an online course.
At the top, you have the number
of students entering
and enrolling.
And as you progress through
these tasks, as you go on with
the course, only a
small number--
staggeringly, only 5% of the
students who enroll--
actually end up completing
the course.
Right?
That's a huge problem.
As it turns out, learning still
requires certain basic
elements that we were used to
in the physical classroom
experience.
It requires help and direct
connection with your tutor.
You need help.
You need to go up to a teacher,
ask about your hard
questions, about
your problems.
You still need hands-on
experience.
And collaborating and studying
in a peer group is always much
better, both for your learning
and for the fun aspect, than
doing it all alone.
So as you heard in the keynotes
today, we at Google
are very passionate about
online education, about
learning in general.
And so some of us on the Google+
product team and the
engineering team, we really
started thinking about these
problems hard and said, what
are the tools that we can
build that can help people who
are actually innovating in the
education space?
And social learning is the term
that's kind of talked
about a lot, but the whole
idea is simple.
While we've see the benefits
of online education--
whether it's bringing down the
cost, providing access to
people who would have never
dreamt of getting education
from Stanford and MIT if they
were not in this country,
we've brought that access.
That's been all positive
change.
But there are certain social
aspects that are critical.
The engagement that we had in
the class, in the peer group,
out of the class--
that was very critical to the
whole learning experience.
So how do you do that?
How do you mimic that positive
aspect of a classroom
experience and bring it to
the online education?
So first, let me talk about a
few features that we have in
Google+ that can help.
I'm not saying they'll solve it
all 100%, but that can help
provide that virtual classroom
feel when you're doing an
online course.
So the first one is Hangouts,
and we had a big launch today.
It's the communications
product that we have.
You can message.
You can do multi-way video chat
with up to 10 people.
Now, imagine a study group,
which has students from Asia,
Africa, all studying the
same course online,
from the United States.
How do you interact
face to face?
This is one tool that
can really help.
And we'll see in the second part
of the session some of
the experiments that we did and
kind of the learnings we
had from that.
The other product that
we have is what we
call Hangouts On Air.
This is our broadcast product.
You can have a conversation with
up to 10 people, but you
can stream it live over YouTube
using this product.
It's the same setup.
It's easy to use.
You don't need a studio
environment.
You don't need any production
work that you need to do in
order to create one of
these broadcasts.
Now, this product, it turns out,
is really helpful if a
teacher wants to interact with
certain students and others
want to tune in.
So you can imagine during office
hours that a professor
sets a time, takes questions
from the students.
They all come in, but there's
a lot more students who can
watch that live or watch that
recording archived.
Because through this product,
we actually
put it back on YouTube.
We archive those clips
on YouTube that you
can go back and see.
Google+ Sign In actually gives
you a single, unified identity
that you can carry across all
of these things, whether you
have an app, whether you're
using Drive, whether you're
doing Hangouts.
All of that is just enabled
by the single sign on.
And there's another feature that
we have in Google+ called
Communities.
We launched this a few months
ago, which enables people,
based on certain common
interests, to come together.
These are not people who are
your friends or you know
necessarily in your real life.
But you share a common thread
with which you can interact in
this Groups kind
of environment.
And again, we'll see examples
how this has proved to be
really popular with
students as well.
So instead of talking a lot
more about these features,
what I'm going to do is
show you an example.
And this example is from
MIT Media Lab.
They have a course around
creative learning, which
traditionally was never held
online, which they
collaborated with Lifelong
Kindergarten,
and they put it online.
And here's what the
professors did.
They first created a lightweight
sign up.
Just put in your email address,
and you sign up for
the course.
None of the registration
deadlines, submitting forms,
none of that stuff.
So it's really easy.
Then, they created a Google+
Community for these students,
and almost 10,000 of these
students who enrolled for the
course actually became members
of this community.
And it became a rich forum for
them to feel like they're part
of a class.
So they would post things,
interact, ask questions, all
of that stuff through
this Community.
And the third thing that the
professor did was actually
start streaming all his seminars
at Hangouts on Air.
So anybody can tune in.
If they miss a particular a
seminar, they can go back to
YouTube and watch it.
And again, it plays well
with the whole
self-paced learning module.
You only proceed once you've
mastered the concept.
You can pause, rewind, do it
at you own pace pretty much
from anywhere.
The second interesting thing
that happened when these
professors did this was how
students reacted to that.
And it turns out that if you
give tools in the hands of
students that are going to help
them create classroom
experiences, they're going
to really run with it.
So students in this particular
class created more than 450
Google+ Communities.
Think of these as study groups
that we were all accustomed to
when we went to school.
Here's a map showing that class
enrollment across the world.
And the reason I put it up here
is it's very important.
All of online education
is pretty much
geographic by nature.
You have students enrolling
from different
parts of the world.
This is what your typical
class would look like.
And that's where the challenge
and the tools come into play
when you want to create a more
cohesive community and provide
the classroom feel.
What else did the students do?
You know, when you
give them tools,
they'll do creative things.
So here was the attempt of all
these students to get to know
each other.
They created these
intro videos.
They put it on YouTube,
and they kind of
shared with each other.
So now, you can imagine you're
taking a class by MIT.
You don't live in the US.
Your students who are actually
enrolled with you are from
different parts of the world.
You've never met them, but you
have some tools in your hands
to be able to mimic
that experience.
Here's what the MIT professors
in the Media Lab told us about
their experience with
these tools.
These are quotes from them.
I'm not going to read them.
As you can see, these are the
tools that will help them
actually make the transition,
bridge the gap between online
and offline learning
experience.
We've worked with a number of
partners who've been using
Google+ features in some form or
the other, integrating some
of these things that
we've done.
But I specifically want to call
Pamela from Coursera to
come and talk about
her experience.
And the reason we kind of chose
Coursera to try out a
bunch of things is they share
a common passion with us in
making improvements, but
also the philosophy
around let's tweak.
Let's iterate.
Let's learn, and let's get to
a place where our tools can
actually add a lot of
value to the users.
So Pamela's going to talk about
what experiments they
did with us, what their
learnings were.
Take it away.
PAMELA FOX: Hi, everyone.
How are you?
Yay.
All right.
Cool.
So I'm a product engineer
at Coursera.
I work on the student-facing
features, which is perhaps
what you would experience
if any of you have
actually used it.
Can you raise your hands
if you have?
Wow.
All right.
I've never had that many people
raise their hands.
I guess we're kind of
mainstream now.
Only in San Francisco.
Everywhere else, no
one's heard of it.
So for people in other parts
of the world, Coursera is
massively open online
courses offered by
universities and partners.
We actually have courses from
the Exploratorium in San
Francisco, which I think is
awesome, for any of you guys
who've actually gone there
and wandered around.
So we have a huge range
of courses.
My mom just finished
Heterogeneous Parallel
Programming and got 110%.
And we also had a bunch of
people just finish Canine
Theriogenology, which is, I
think, dog reproduction.
But I haven't taken the class,
so I'm not an expert.
But the point is that we've got
courses across a bunch of
different genres and a lot of
different sorts of students
taking them for lots of sorts
of different reasons, right?
And there's usually about 50
going on at any time, because
our courses do actually
run on a schedule.
And we do that on purpose
because, actually, of social
learning, right?
So if there are people taking
a course at the same time as
you, you're more likely to
actually be able to form a
cohort and feel like there's
other people doing it, right?
So when I tweet out that I'm
working on my homework for a
class, I'll just get people who
randomly tweet back that
they are too.
And it's like, oh,
right, right.
I forgot.
There's actually people
doing it with me.
This is cool.
However, we've got
tons of classes.
And in any given class, we've
got between 30,000 and even up
to 160,000 students enrolled.
And they're from all
over the world.
But when you get into
the class, this is
what it looks like.
It looks like a class.
It looks like it's
got lectures.
It's got assignments.
It's got a lot of text.
And you look at it, and you
don't see people, right?
You just see stuff
you have to do.
Which is cool, because the
classes can be quite
interesting.
But we need a people aspect to
everything we do, right?
So we've been trying to figure
out how can we actually help
students feel a connection to
other people inside this
learning experience, right?
And we can think of this in a
few different axes, right?
So what are the different
forms of
communications that we have?
So we have synchronous
communication, where we can
talk back and forth
very quickly.
And that's good for having
very excited, energetic
discussions.
We've got asynchronous
communication, so we can post
in a forum thread, and then a
few hours later, somebody else
posts back.
And we can take our time to
come up with responses--
also known as email.
And these are both valuable
forms of communication, and
they both have their uses.
I used to work on Google Wave
in Australia, and it did an
awesome job at having both
asynchronous and synchronous
communication, despite
everything else we
can say about it.
[APPLAUSE]
PAMELA FOX: But the point is
that we need both of those
forms, right?
And we also have the difference
between in-person,
face-to-face communications
and online, potentially
faceless communications,
right?
And we love these in-person,
face-to-face communications,
because it's like, wow, I
can actually see you.
And I know there's people
watching me, which feels a lot
better than giving
a talk to no one.
So you feel much more intimate
when you can
actually see somebody.
You have this whole
different level of
intimacy with them, right?
But then, you can have this
other approach where you're
online, maybe you're even being
anonymous, and there's
actually good reasons for
having that as well.
Maybe you are in a controversial
class.
We have classes on AIDS and
reproduction, contraception,
all sorts of things that
people don't always
necessarily want to be
forthright with their person.
Because there are weird people
in the world that might do
stuff to you.
OK.
So we want both of these
axes in terms of
communication, right?
So what do we have there?
We've got our forums
and wikis.
Some people form online
chat rooms.
They use stuff like StudyRoom.
We encourage people to go to
meetup.com and actually create
meetups and meet up in person.
That, of course, doesn't scale
that well, because there's not
going to be somebody in every
single part of the world--
not yet.
So where does Google
Hangouts fit in?
It's synchronous communication,
right?
We can talk back and forth
over the video.
And it's also kind
of in between
being online and in-person.
It's almost like it's
in person, right?
So me and Amit, we actually
never met until an hour ago.
But it was OK, because I have a
Hangout with him every week.
And I feel like I know him,
because the Hangout software
doesn't have that skin softening
thing yet or
anything, so I am really
familiar with his
wrinkles and stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
PAMELA FOX: So it's cool.
So it's so close to being in
person that I've actually lost
track of who I know in
person and who I've
just seen in a Hangout.
So it's this really interesting
part of the axes here.
So we're interested in using
Google Hangouts to help our
students connect in a
few different ways.
So first, we want to help
students connect to teachers.
So unfortunately, we
have a massive
student-teacher ratio, right?
In a typical class, like when
I teach classes on the
weekends, we usually try
to have 1 to 10 ratios.
That's a good ratio.
Online, we've got ratios like
1 to 25,000, right?
Which is kind of huge
and ridiculous.
How can students feel connected
to a teacher when
they're just one of thousands
and thousands of students?
So one of the things that
teachers do is they hold these
Google Hangouts On Air.
So a specific example here.
This is from the Irrational
Behavior class.
And that class had this peer
assessment, and people weren't
particularly happy with the way
that they got graded by
their peers.
And they had a lot of questions
about how the system
worked and about the rubric, and
there was a lot of angst
going on in the forums.
And so the professor, he did
respond in the forums, and he
did post some announcements.
But he just wanted to make
sure that students were
actually feeling like he
was listening to them.
So he put together a Google
Hangout, and we also had a
Coursera guy in there as well.
He invited 10 of the vocal
students from the forums in
there, and he invited everybody
else to watch this
Hangout and invited everyone to
submit questions via Google
Spreadsheet.
So this really helped students
feel like Dan was actually
listening to their questions.
So just like Larry Page finished
the keynote by just
saying, hey, if you have a
question, come ask me, that
kind of helped us feel more
connected to Larry, right?
Like, oh, wow, Larry is just
going to respond to us just
live like that?
So the same thing here.
It helped students feel like the
professors actually care
and like they potentially
could have a
connection too, right?
If you see another student
connecting,
you're like, oh, wow.
OK, they're just like me.
I guess we're all on
the same level.
And so we have lots and lots
of professors that do these
Google Hangouts and solicit
questions beforehand
and stuff like that.
And generally, everyone
loves this format.
So that's cool.
But there's a harder problem,
and that's how do we help
students connect to
other students?
And the reason this is hard is
because we've got thousands
and thousands of students,
right?
And I actually wrote JavaScript
to try and generate
as many dots as I could
to get on this slide,
but that's only 25,000.
I'm sorry.
So we wanted to help students
connect to each other, but the
problem is that they obviously
can't connect to every single
other person.
So how do we get them
into groups?
Or how do we decide which clumps
of them are actually
going to connect, right?
Because for something like a
Hangout, the ideal number is
somewhere between 5 to 12.
You don't want to have 25,000
people in a Hangout.
That would be a really, really
interesting experiment that we
could try maybe later today,
but not for this.
So let's go over a few
things that we tried.
So our first experiment was in
the Think Again class, which
is a class on reasoning
and arguing.
So it kind of made sense that,
hey, these people might be
interested in having
some discussions.
They are in an entire class
about discussing.
So what we did is that we
created these Hangout rooms.
And we had three rooms that were
persistent, so they were
always there, which was
Meet Someone New.
And we tried to encourage people
not to use pickup lines
in that one, but, I mean, if two
people are going to meet
in Coursera, I think that's
also cool too.
So let me know if that
happens to you.
I think that's why my mom
is taking the Parallel
Programming, honestly.
We have Talk About the
Class, and then we
have Discuss Lectures.
Those are our general rooms.
And then, the professor would
actually come up with
discussion questions relevant
to each week, and we would
create five new rooms each
week about that.
So at any point, the students
could go into these Hangout
rooms, and whoever was there,
they could chat with, right?
So that was interesting.
And in terms of code,
it was pretty easy.
We just used some JavaScript,
and we stuck a few divs on the
page and had the JavaScript
populate those divs.
And the Hangouts team helped
make these widgets for us to
try this out.
Now, for our second experiment,
we did this in the
Irrational Behavior class.
And I was excited about this,
because I actually did take
this class.
I finished it last night at 2:00
AM, the first class I've
ever finished.
So that was really exciting for
me, to use my own product.
So we had 140,000 students
enrolled in this.
And here, what we did is we did
scheduled Hangouts, right?
So the first experiment was
like, OK, what happens if we
just have rooms that you can
just enter all the time?
And we saw problems there with
the timing in terms of people
entering at the wrong times
and being out of sync.
So we did these scheduled
Hangouts.
And here, you could actually
see a list of upcoming
Hangouts, and the TAs would
come up with lots of cool
ideas for interesting
Hangouts.
And you could say,
I want to attend.
You would get a thingie
on your calendar.
You would get a reminder
from your calendar.
And you go and enter the
Hangout and chat with
everybody who is there, right?
So that definitely helped a lot
in terms of getting people
all there at the same time.
So the class is officially
over as of last night.
And there were 65 Hangouts over
six weeks, and every user
saw an average of five other
users during those Hangouts.
Pretty cool.
In terms of the code, once
again, really simple
JavaScript.
I'm kind of embarrassed
to put the code here,
because it was so easy.
And I was like, thank you,
Google, for making it this
easy, so I can go into
other things.
And we also experimented
with letting
students schedule Hangouts.
And we would actually prompt
them in the forums to say, oh,
hey, maybe you'd like to start
a Hangout on this topic.
And that would just link to this
page that would tell them
how to start a Hangout, right?
So we didn't actually
see as many students
doing this, very few.
And we're not sure exactly
why that is.
Maybe they're intimidating.
They don't feel like they have
the authority on it.
They seemed to much prefer
joining the Hangouts that were
started by the TA.
So here's what we learned.
So students really, really liked
being able to visualize
their classmates, right?
The fact that they could
actually see other people in
the class was like, oh, wow, I'm
really in a class, right?
So in San Francisco, I have the
fortunate ability to just
walk around and find people that
are using Coursera, which
is really cool.
But if you're walking around
Chile or Argentina, you may
not just randomly find
Courserians on the street.
So being able to actually see
that there's other people
doing it along with
you was really,
really powerful, right?
Even for the people who didn't
even have good conversations,
they were like, it
didn't matter.
It was just cool that
I could see people.
There were people.
I guess we're all just really
lonely on the internet now.
And they also really liked
diverse opinions.
Both in our forums and in our
Hangouts, we hear this a lot,
that students really, really
appreciate getting thrown into
these situations where they're
kind of forced to hear other
people's opinions.
Because they just happen to be
in a class with these other
people, and they can't help but
hear from people from all
over the world.
So the Hangouts help with that
quite a bit as well, because
you actually get to have real
discussions with people from
all over the world and learn
quite a bit about how things
work everywhere.
So that's what they loved.
But we also learned a lot
about what made for good
Hangouts and what would improve
the experience.
So this is what good
conversations need.
I could not be talking about
Hangouts, and all of these
things would still
be true, right?
So you need etiquette.
You need some sort of rules that
you're following to have
good conversations.
Now, you might think
it's obvious.
But remember, we have people
from all over the world.
So the etiquette that we may
have for our conversations may
be different from the etiquette
that they have for
conversations in other
countries.
So we would actually have people
write these wiki pages
and forum posts with suggestions
of etiquette, and
people would banter back and
forth about what the correct
etiquette was.
And that's where the discussion
came up about is it
appropriate to pickup
people in Hangouts.
Because in some countries,
maybe it is, right?
So etiquette is actually
increasingly important when
you're doing something online
in a massive setting.
Shared language.
It seems obvious, but if you
get on a Hangout, and you
don't speak the same language
as the other person, it's
going to be a little hard
to communicate.
So that just makes everything
harder.
Focus.
So this is why we tried to have
Hangouts that were around
particular topics.
When we just had really general
Hangouts, like the
Discuss a Lecture, people didn't
necessarily know what
to talk about.
But when the Hangouts were like,
hey, design your own
irrationality experiment
following this rubric here and
talk about what you're
going to test, it's a
very focused topic.
And people come in there, and
they know that they're there
for a reason, right?
Flow--
so flow is something that's
difficult to have in
conversations, right?
I'm sure we've all been in
awkward conversations where
it's like, it's going
really great, really
great, really great.
And then suddenly, it's
like [RASPBERRY].
And you're like, aww,
this is awkward.
So that can be even worse
online, because you can't kind
of wander away and regroup
and join other groups.
You're kind of just sitting
there, staring at each other,
going like, OK, all right, we've
got to get this flow
back, right?
And it's just something that
happens with human
conversations.
It's not always got that
perfect flow, right?
So people found it helped when
there'd be somebody there who
was really good at guiding
the conversation.
And that's sort of a certain
personality type, the people
that are really good at
realizing that a conversation
is about to dip and kind of
bringing it back up, maybe
bringing it back into
focus on something.
And that would make for much
more successful conversations.
Now, of course, timing.
As I was saying, when we just
did the rooms that you could
just enter at any time, we found
that people would just
enter at any time,
and it would just
always be off, right?
So you want to try and get
people starting that Hangout
at roughly the same time, so
that they're not sitting
around and waiting.
I mean, any of you guys who've
had a video conference
probably know what I mean
about timing, right?
You really want to get that
timing really well.
And finally, comfort.
Some people may not feel
comfortable suddenly being on
video alongside five other
people, video faces that
they've never seen
before, right?
So how can we make people
feel more comfortable?
Maybe having the TA there helps,
or maybe having them
meet those people in the forums
before, maybe that helps.
So that's something we found
as well is that the comfort
level was not always there.
But those are just some
experiments that we've done
over the last few months.
And we want to do a lot more
experiments, right?
That's kind of what we do.
We just keep doing experiments
to see what works and learn
and try and do the
next experiment.
Because every time we do an
experiment, we think we're
going to have a result.
And we're like, oh.
Oh, I see.
We got something we
didn't expect.
Because here's the thing about
humans-- they just do the
damnedest things, right?
Especially in groups.
Actually, just any time.
So we've got a few ideas in mind
for what we want to do in
the future.
So one thing that would be
great is to actually time
Hangouts around watching
lectures.
So if you're watching a lecture
say, hey, there's also
five other people watching
this lecture.
Maybe you want to discuss
it afterwards, right?
And there, you've both
got the timing, and
you've got the context.
You've got something to discuss,
and you've got people
discuss it with.
And luckily, I think in a lot
of our classes, we do have
enough people watching lectures
at the same time that
we might be able to do that.
Another thing we can do is
having Hangouts more strictly
around discussions and say,
hey, there are five people
that are actually on this thread
watching it right now.
Maybe you'd like to just jump
into a real-time Hangout and
just chat it out there.
Especially for these threads
that just get
really long, right?
It'd be much better just to
do that face to face.
And finally, I really want to
improve the comfort level
people have by actually
creating
groups inside our classes.
So we don't really have
groups right now.
People can create groups on
social networks if they want
to, but we really want
to start creating
groups for our students.
Like say, hey, we found 10
people in San Francisco that
seem to be on the same
commitment level of you.
Maybe you'd like to
form a group.
Here's some forum threads.
Here's some Hangout tools.
Go at it.
Do something, right?
Because when you're in a group
with people, and you're kind
of in a persistent group,
then all these things
are going to be better.
Because you're going
to start to feel
comfortable with each other.
You'll start to have
a shared etiquette.
When you decide to have a
Hangout together, you'll all
actually show up, because you
have a social pressure to
actually feel like you're
supposed to be there.
So all of that can actually
improve everything that we've
talked about.
Now, the Google Hangouts team
didn't tell me that they're
also adding chat to it, so I
just added this slide in.
So the interesting thing is now
Google Hangouts actually
will encompass from synchronous
to asynchronous,
because we've got this chat
tied into it too, right?
And I think that will be
really interesting to
experiment with and see, hey,
what happens if we give
students rooms where they can
start off in a chat mode and
then go into video mode once
they feel comfortable, right?
Because I think that could
help with ramping up our
comfort level and helping people
find a topic, right?
You start off chatting.
You realize there's actually
something that you do want to
chat about with the other people
in the chat room, and
then you go into that
Hangout because
you've decided on that.
So I'm excited to experiment
with that once the team gives
me access to it.
So generally, what I learned
at Coursera and what I keep
learning is that it's really
important to experiment and
try and come up with lightweight
experiments.
So I wrote as little code as I
could in order to come up with
these experiments.
And track everything.
You'll learn from students,
and you'll learn that
communities interact in very,
very interesting ways.
And it's a pretty cool
thing to do.
[APPLAUSE]
AMIT FULAY: So I think
we're right on time.
That brings us to the end
of this presentation.
I do want to emphasize the
last point that Pamela
referred to, which is this is
broadly applicable to all the
online communities
that you have.
So while we talked a lot about
online education and learning
and students and professors, I
think if you have a community
of developers, sites where you
have people discussing health
issues, sports fans, whatever
community it is that is
geographically distributed, is
tied together by a shared
interest, I think we have
features like Google+
Communities and Hangouts that
can help you bridge that gap.
So we would definitely love more
of you to participate in
kind of experimenting these
things with us.
And there's a short link here
where you can submit a form if
you're willing to kind of work
on some of these things.
If you have ideas, get
in touch with us.
We have a team that kind
of does partnerships.
They'll be monitoring this.
We would love to
work with you.
With that, I want
to leave a few
minutes here for questions.
So if you can use the mic,
that'd be great.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Jan.
I liked your early presentation
with a lot of
photos of smiling kids.
However, a lot of them seemed
to be under 13.
Can you comment on under 13?
What's Google+ doing, Hangouts
availability in K-12?
AMIT FULAY: There's nothing
I can add beyond what our
established policies are, which
is you need to be 13 or
over for signing
up for Google+.
So I don't think we're
changing any
of that right now.
AUDIENCE: The information on the
lessons learned, did that
come from surveys distributed
after the course, or was there
a Hangout extension that you
use to measure people's
responses to the questions
asked?
How did you gather the data that
you used to say, these
are people's responses?
AMIT FULAY: So if I get your
question correctly, how did we
get the data on how
the Hangouts were?
AUDIENCE: In how people were
using the system, what they
liked about it, what they
didn't like about it.
AMIT FULAY: So we did a
combination, as we do in all
the products that we do at
Google, a combination of
quantitative, looking at
metrics, as well as
qualitative studies.
So we actually had a form that
we asked students to fill
every time they did a Hangout
on the Coursera site, so we
got some amount of
data from that.
We looked at our metrics, kind
of how many students would
initiate a Hangout, how long
they stayed, how big the
sessions were, what were the
number of students in every
given Hangout, and was there a
correlation between number of
participants and the length
of the Hangout.
We also talked to
the professors.
We talked to the TAs and kind
of got data from them around
what their experience was,
what could be better.
So we used multiple channels
here to collect data.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm part of a group of
Australian teachers that use
Hangouts to talk about cool
stuff every week, and we
really want some way of
having a back channel.
So there's 10 of us in the
Hangout, and we're discussing
things between us.
Only one of us is talking at the
time, but then there are
lots of other teachers who are
using Hangout on Air who want
to ask questions as well.
At the moment, they're sort
of half on Twitter.
You mentioned there's a Google
Spreadsheet the professor used
to ask questions.
Is there any better way of doing
this, or can I hope for
one to come?
AMIT FULAY: That's
great feedback.
We've actually heard that, not
just in the education space,
but from a lot of folks who've
been using Hangouts On Air,
whether it's in media
or other celebrities
doing Hangouts on Air.
And one of the things that they
have asked for is how can
we better interact with people
who are watching on.
And so, we've got that feedback,
and we'll definitely
try and solve that.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I'm with a start-up that
works on helping students take
notes on videos on sites like
Coursera, and it leverages
Google Docs.
And we're wondering what Google
would be doing for
start-ups that try to build
these on this ecosystem.
AMIT FULAY: Absolutely.
So we actually have a platform,
an API set that,
just like Google Docs, is an app
that you can run within a
Hangout or YouTube,
for that matter.
We have an API that's
available publicly.
We launched it last year.
So you can use that to write an
app, a note-taking app or
whatever you want to do to
enhance that learning
experience.
We actually do have a session
later in the day at 4:00 PM on
some of the changes we've done
in that Hangouts platform,
which I highly recommend
you should attend.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Christine
from Scoot & Doodle.
And we have been building inside
Google's Hangouts API,
and I was hoping you can share
with all of the other
developers that are looking to
hear more about what you're
doing with the Google
Hangouts API.
AMIT FULAY: We have a
lot more to share.
I actually just did a
post with all the
changes we've made.
We're moving to a new, faster
development model, and there's
a lot of new functionality
that we've added.
Again, there's a session by
Richard Dunn, who's a
technical lead on the platform,
later in the day at
4 o'clock today.
I think you should attend.
And thanks for your work.
Scoot & Doodle, for those of you
who don't know, was one of
the early partners we had
building on top of the
Hangouts platform, and they
have a great app.
So great to see you,
Christine.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question for Ms. Fox.
You had there a lot of
feedbacks, and some of them
were surprising, and I didn't
have a chance to read it all.
Could you share your really
surprising insights and
feedbacks on what was quite
unexpected results of your
experiments?
PAMELA FOX: Well, I guess we'll
be sharing the slides
later so that you can
look over the actual
quotes I had on there.
I pulled them out of forums
and out of surveys.
I think the things that we were
surprised at was the kind
of ways that students wanted to
participate in the Hangouts.
So we see a lot of students
want to participate in
Hangouts, but they don't
necessarily want to be the
ones that start one.
So we kind of expected to see
a lot more students want to
start Hangouts.
So I think what I've learned
there is that I want to do
more experiments where
actually the
professor kind of says--
because we do have this one
professor in psychology that
he wants to end every week by
saying, all right, this is
what we talked about
this week.
Now, go sign up for a slot and
discuss this for 30 minutes.
So he's actually going to
direct his students.
He wants to direct them to do
it, because it's exactly what
he does at college.
At college, he'll have a
physical sign-up sheet around
there, right?
So there, you would feel more
license to actually be signing
up for it, because somebody has
told you this is something
we want you to do.
It's really intimidating to be
the one that says, I'm going
to start a conversation.
That's hugely intimating,
right?
When I'm at a party, I
literally hide in the bathroom.
Because it's scary.
But if somebody goes and invites
me into conversation,
and says, hey, this is Pamela,
she's part of the group.
I'm like, all right, cool.
I will totally participate.
So it is very scary to be the
initiator of anything.
So if we can license people
and enable students to do
that, I think that they'll
end up having really good
experiences that they
want to have.
I think it's like a lot
of social experiences.
If it was up to me, I would just
spend all my time being a
hermit and not going outside.
But then when I do outside, I
actually quite enjoy myself.
But somebody has to give me that
license and has to enable
me, so I want to enable more
students to do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AMIT FULAY: And just to add to
that, I think that was one of
the big surprises
for me as well.
Which is, as engineers, we're
just trained to think about
how to solve certain things
technically, like what are the
features I can add, how can
I do things that's easier.
But there are some real social
kind of issues, like if
students are shy to speak up, if
there's a language barrier,
they feel awkward, they don't
want to turn on the camera.
And those are much tougher
problems to solve.
So I think that's both daunting
as well as exciting,
because we need to figure
out how to do that
in an online world.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Belle from
Cal Poly Pomona.
I'm an instructions designer for
university higher ed, and
I really liked about the
Google+ Community part.
But we are actually big
in accessibility part.
I know that you guys do
a lot of the video,
audio, those thing.
Can you guys talk about some
kind of accessibility, like
how to integrate with the
closed captioning?
If there's a video synchronous,
asynchronous, or
anywhere, Hangouts
on Air and stuff.
AMIT FULAY: So as you know,
Google has Translate and a lot
of the technologies.
On YouTube, we have
closed captioning.
So some of these broadcasts,
when they're archived, we can
turn on the closed captioning.
So that's one solution
that exists.
In terms of real conversations
and how do we bridge that
language barrier, I think that's
a much tougher problem.
But there's a lot of people at
Google who are looking at it.
You saw some of the
conversational search stuff
that we are doing.
You can imagine using some of
that technology that we have
and see how we can kind of
bridge the language barrier.
But it's not something that's
going to happen overnight.
But there's folks working
on that problem.
PAMELA FOX: I think with our
videos, because we actually
have an accessibility contract--
since we work with
universities, we have
to be accessible--
so all of our videos must
have English subtitles.
So I think what happens for some
of the Hangouts is that
they get recorded on Air, so
they can download the video.
So I think they upload them to
our platform, which then kicks
off a subtitling job with the
subtitle service we use.
So I think actually for a lot of
the office hours that they
do with Hangouts on Air, the
professors do create
subtitles for them.
So you could still create
subtitles using
other services as well.
AMIT FULAY: All right.
It's showing me 30
seconds left.
If there are other questions,
we've got a
short amount of time.
I can take one more.
If not, thanks a lot for
attending the session and
coming
to Google I/O. [APPLAUSE]